[Music]
okay i guess we'll seek a 10 minute game
i really wanted to do a higher time
control for
with the speedrun but nobody's
i want to find a game so there we go a
thousand okay
we're going with e4
okay e4 e5 and
once again i'm gonna play an opening
that i i recommend to
uh to some beginners
uh as a way of practicing getting all of
your pieces out i mean i know it sounds
very
very uh banal to say that when you learn
a very specific opening system
oftentimes you the fundamentals get kind
of buried
uh beneath all of the theory that you
learn
and that opening is the four night
scotch so you start by playing the four
knights knight c3 knight f6
and then you play d4 which is the scotch
this is called the four knight scotch
now it's not just one of those boring
openings that beginners play it's also
an opening that's very popular at the
highest level
and it's quite dangerous for black if
black is not very precise with the
theory
so we're not compromising on
on ambition of bishop c5 is
a well-known inaccuracy in this line
who can tell me the reason why
and it's very important to go for this
line
without fearing
certain responses that i'm going to talk
about after the stream and the move is
knight takes e5
the move that i think a lot of people
fear is bishop takes f2 check
and in general this is a big reason why
people don't go for this type of idea in
many positions
but bishop takes f2 it turns out is not
only not scary but essentially losing
for black
and i'll talk about that
after the game okay pawn d4 forking back
to the miners
yeah and what's gonna happen here is
black has to choose which of these
pieces to give away
um
what black should do as as many of you
know is go bishop d6 that is the
traditional and the best response
to this kind of idea
what a lot of people do here is they
play bishop takes d4
kind of instinctively and that's very
bad
because you don't want to give away the
bishop this early in the game and then
the queen starts skewering the knight
and black could end up just losing the
game there very quickly
let's see how he reacts
bishop b6 okay that's
also not great because
black is not even gonna get a pawn for
the
uh
for the fork
okay so d6
all right so we have a choice here we
can take on d6 we can also be fancy
we can play a fancy move here that sets
a little bit of a trap
who can tell me what move i'm thinking
about
i mean anytime there's a standoff
between the kings between the queens and
the kings are uncastled you should be
thinking about this idea uh when your
opponent's pieces are not very well
developed
and one way of thinking about this is
that the queen is undefended by anything
other than the king
so let's go bishop c4 if he takes c5
we play bishop takes f7 check
now this isn't just a cheap trap we're
also developing one of our pieces to a
really good square and he falls right
into it she takes f7
if king takes f7 whoa he's going right
into it now one thing you have to be
very careful about
is to make sure if the white king was on
e2 here if our king was on e2
we would fall right into bishop g4 check
um
but
but it's not right and that's the one
thing you have to check when you
essentially
when you perform this combination that
was pretty one-sided nine move game
the only thing i really have to talk
about here is the moment we took on e5
thank you bismo funyuns for the prime
now reasons people are afraid to take on
e5 one reason i've heard from some
students is a move like queen f6 which
looks like it forks the knight in the
pawn
this fork is very easy to defend against
with the prosaic knight f3 you can just
drop the knight back
you could also go knight d3 although i
like this move a little bit less even
though it hits the bishop it blocks our
own bishop and i feel like this and it
blocks the other bishop so knight on d3
is quite awkward
another reason is queen h4 people get
scared of this move
and here we can either go g3 or we can
go knight d3 here unfortunately we can't
go knight f3
i like the move g3 here
queen has to come back and then
we can play knight f3 and fiance our
bishop since we've already gone g3
okay
and the third reason is bishop takes f2
check thank you roger spacky for the
prime
the thing to understand about this
position is that white's king is
temporarily weak
we are going to castle by hand we're
going to move the bishop out go rook f1
can't you one not a problem
daniel dan for the gift on the other
hand what's not temporary is our control
over the center and our development
advantage we're gonna go d4
all of these checks are not scary queen
f6 check we just tuck our king back on
g1
and what's going to happen is that okay
black kind of has to drop the knight
back
now we start the process let's say
bishop d3 or bishop c4
uh i would probably prefer bishop d3
just to solidify our center
let's say black plays d6
because if black plays knight f6 here
what very powerful move can we respond
with
yeah e5 sends the knight back to g8
which is why probably black will play d6
and then we play rook f1 king g1 and
here's the thing not only did we castle
by hand but the fact that the f-file is
open is good for white so bishop takes
f2 actually did us a favor
and the reason it's good for white is
because after bishop g5
uh the pressure on the knight becomes
instantly unbearable we're threatening
bishop takes ft destroying black's pawn
cover thank you shogun for the five
really appreciate it understood thank
you st law official and lots of subs now
somebody mentioned one point i want to
address which is that on queen f6 check
king g1
isn't it the case that the rook on h1 is
going to be hemmed in
and yes it is the case but we're going
to get that rook out
thank you chaos shield after knight g6
we can proceed with knight d5 for
forcing the queen back to d8
and um
[Music]
you know there's no huge urgency to get
the rook
out of h1 it's not like it's necessary
at this very moment but if you wanted to
get the rook out you could again
play bishop d3
let's say black plays d6
then if you wanted he could play h3
let's say black plays c6 chases our
knight back and then develops
his own knight and go king h2 and then
rook f1
yeah we spent a couple of moves so black
wasted so many tempi moving back and
forth that this is totally justified and
we still have
the center and we have
uh we have everything we we could
possibly need here
okay
what's going on
okay i thought
people in the chat were
worried about something
oh prime okay nice yeah definitely sub
with prime knight takes e5 d4 the proper
way is bishop d6 to respond to this d
takes e5 bishop takes c5
and why this better we have a pawn in
the center black doesn't we have a
slight development advantage this bishop
on e5 is quite awkward it can be
attacked with the move f4 later he rated
nc17 male blue 420 and ant source all
subbing with a prime there we go
so this is just
very very pleasant for white cocky 16
thank you for the prime
amazing
bishop b6 is the first mistake it gives
up upon for no compensation and after d6
bishop c4 comes the second mistake he
takes e5
how should black play here well he
should go 97 and castle i mean at least
uh limit the losses to a pawn and of
course here he should go king e7 this is
the last chance to stay in the game
who can tell me
uh a good move here for white it's
actually not so easy for white to play
accurately in this position
there's a lot of tempting moves here and
some of them aren't as good as they look
white's best move is to sub with prime
yeah but let's say white's second best
move well knight d5 gives up the bishop
bishop g5 check looks like it wins the
game
but black can block with a knight so
this is not as impressive as it looks
other attempts bishop takes g8 is fine
but then black can trade queens and then
take on g and we got an end game do we
really want an end game when the king is
this week
so what do we need to do here we need to
avoid the queen trade
and at the same time we need to keep
this bishop protected so i really like
the move queen f3 uh queen h5 i like
less because of knight f6 hitting the
queen
and the queen has to stay anchored to
the bishop so you're probably going to
have to go bishop g5 here and this leads
to some complications queen f3 i think
eliminates all complications because if
black plays knight f6
uh
i you know the simplest is to drop the
bishop back and then castle and
you know we're grooving here we're in
great shape the king is stuck in the
center
if black tries to castle by hand he's
not going to get very far because we're
stopping the king from getting to g8 so
here we can go bishop g5 and then knight
d5
this is really really good
okay
cool
of course this loses on the spot
[Music]